the release of troubling body cam
footage has prompted an investigation
into the death of a black teenager at
the hands of U.S Park police 17-year-old
Delano Martin was shot and killed in a
car on March 18th in Washington while
officers responded to a report of a
stolen vehicle Jeff PA case has more we
want to warn you some of this video is
disturbing
at least four DC
FIFA officers approached the car early
Saturday morning March 18th a young man
appeared to be sleeping inside police
say the car was stolen and they called
for backup with two U.S Park police
officers responding he says golf just
let him go but don't get inside that car
ignoring that advice those two officers
opened the rear doors and one got in
please
the driver 17 year old Elena Martin
drove off one officer falling ground the
other still in the back seat
Martin's Family says that he was shot in
the back five times he slumped over the
wheel the car crashing into a house
police say a gun was found in the
vehicle Delano Martin leaves behind an
infant son his mother Tara Martin shared
her grief he's my child
he's my son
and they tell you be where I'm at today
you would never understand the doj will
determine if Martin's civil rights were
violated a key moment in the probe will
be when the officer got into the car
Keith Taylor is a former NYPD supervisor
it could be considered an officer
created Jeopardy situation where uh the
the Tactical decisions were not uh
advantageous to the officer because it
placed the officer In Harm's Way
the officers involved have been placed
on administrative leave while there is
an internal investigation the union that
represents the Park police says that the
officers acted appropriately
Vlad
all right Jeff thank you very much